how's it going my name r and welcome
back to tenis Lake this [__] is [__]
terrifying not going to lie you you
[__] things up for me last time then
here the duck thing is down here he's
going to chase us once we get down here
I don't know where I feel about that I
don't know he where he comes from that
little
duckling huh maybe he's not afos anymore
what a
you [__] you suck God damn ah all
right is it in here which [__] door
is
it all right now that thing is going
to there you are I remember you oh [__]
oh [__] oh [__] the duck is after me the
duck is after me the duck is after me
and we click the AR yeah yes I did it no
matter how the dark in the moment Love
and Hope are always possible at the
[__] lie that a [__] lie all right
there all right we're
good I survived we survive hey good
morphe give me that [__] oh it's just
hey more of that [__] give me that I
need that because drugs are bad okay but
good okay whatever it is I am drugs this
I'm taking it do you know why I'll tell
you
why are we back
here no way all it's another place what
is this place pots super tiny pots they
don't even break holy [__] that's
amazing go pot whoa I think I broke
it nothing in the
closet what why's the
crackling hello where did pot go he
duplicated into three really big
pots that's what I think happened oh
we're down here now I don't even know
why we're doing here find the doctor
they
said lame what someone broke down this
door who books we already been through
this last episode as I remember now H
I'm an idiot that is L of
course well then what the [__] are we
doing try to think give me that oil 360
oil
y I'm going to call you Jans all right
Jans I don't ah I don't appreciate your
attitude you're aggressive no one like a
stop
Dan son of a j it's got to be something
with the bookshelves they're [__]
everywhere like one of those books you
oh it's
not what about this room this doesn't
have have books in it that's got to mean
something like life is empty sometimes
or not think got what are you doing
here you try to be funny and [__] try to
Spook me you don't spook
PewDiePie M does not simply spook
PewDiePie okay you probably do it all
right fine see if I care oh you're
guarding this [__] now
Jens hate you Jens I don't even know
what I'm
doing let got it oh another stop was I'm
not wasting any all right let's try and
find
something can I go
underneath there's a candle there it's
very bad it could start a fire
especially in the library it's not very
well
placed
okay oh secret
door I found you how do we move this
that's a problem I can move you but not
the thing behind the
door well it's got to be a lever or some
[__] but they don't hint you that of
course why would they hint you a
lever come on where's the lever
it's got to be
somewhere still have the Easter egg key
all right we are
back oh man what the [__] apparently it
was easy as hell for people to find but
not me you know why I tell you why cuz
you can't inside of the Drone but ah
it's here it's a [__] book here yep
that is pointless thank you for that
game let's make him find I got to
sneeze ah ah what happened to your head
man oh it's skul all
right where is it down the St Library
that's not you say right ah in here all
right
y bye
dadad all by
myself just jumping through what the
hell where the [__] am I
going what the hell is
this a library Labyrinth clever like clb
except Cleverbot ain't that clever oh
Skelly you made it look at the
pict Edward has been acting weirdly I
thought I had convinced him that my
experiments are for the greater good he
doesn't know that for me to carry on
with my experiments keep from truth and
he failed son of failed decided to drink
found out what going on oh he drank the
amn drink one of his didn't count losing
the memory of his wife and children oh
no I remove them from the cabin
count on losing the memory oh that's
pretty whoa why am I ah oh that was me
oh my wife and children oh no they're
dead
no feel so much for the story in this C
St get to me I didn't even get a chance
to pick up the oil come
on when there is nothing left I you
seeing me in loading screen isn't
it h don't mind me you can keep eting
all
right come chapter six [__] yeah chapter
5 was not a good chapter for me there
was a lot of tutorials and walkthroughs
and
whatnot there's nothing to fill with oh
I don't have my thing anymore all right
let's break you did not work
ah whoa whoa whoa chill out no time for
break dancing right now we have not won
this battle yet we cannot go break
whoa
no
no no no I didn't do anything I didn't
do [__] I didn't do [__] how did I even
end up here it's locked isn't it no it's
not L cool it's pretty good what about
this place a long way walking Corridor
I'm sure nothing bad will
happen ah ohly should have didn't all
right this got to be like the grand
finale room or some [__] like that I
don't know I think so look at this you
got SC skull what baby what don't
whisper to me don't
whisper what what is it what do you want
Hello no all all
right this this random
screaming oh look an office hey a bug
come I like a door it's the tiny
door good I love me some things this
room is
amazing no can't go there what no why
I'm not going to touch you
what he
one w wait a second
I where have you been all this play
through I'm not
exactly I am Gonzalez's brother oh look
I sliced that man up you know I py you
know I I don't want to
[Music]
[Applause]
know close close close what the [__]
what the [__] is
you oh [__] why did I do
that where do I
go all right let's hide
here this will work I'm sure it will
away just close my eyes and he'll not
find
me ah this is so bad for
me what are you doing I get out of bunny
you're not a bunny you're not a bunny
you're not a bunny I'm not a bunny oh
what the [__] so fast the hell is
unfair
St bar using
[Music]
[Applause]
H oh I want to go have a leg go leg
let's go let's go together what the hell
yay I'm bumped yeah yeah yeah all right
cool I'm glad you pumped what the hell
did happen in here we were just pting I
thought it was a good yeah yeah huh I
feel sexy tonight look at that come here
pity come here behind the table and make
love to me all right yeah you like this
[__] pity you like when it scared you
does that turn you on oh yeah look at
that you like my sexy body don't you I'm
a little shy you know this is how I roll
This Is How I Roll let me touch your
face pity oh I like that touch my butt
pity do it you can do it you can do it P
yeah yeah oh yeah you like what the hell
stupid why did I go in there SA I'm
sorry P I didn't know he was there I'm
so sorry don't put me there it's hot son
of a
[__] ah what is up with this place what
is my land I'm
doing I don't know what I'm doing with
my
life Amnesia man it will get to you well
maybe I'm not supposed to go down
here I don't
know it could be this is that there are
other rooms as well I wish I had my ladn
though I wish I had that
[__] I mean she's not a [__] it's more
like a girl that never had love this is
where I started what if I go over
here a hey there sir what was
that what was that
oh cool what it's down there I'll save
for now thank you very much
I don't know what's going
on all right let's Shi
this I don't want to go to anywh way I
just want to go home and cry to Mama
Mama what all right why is it shaking
fine now don't go there then stupid
shaking place doesn't matter to
me
[Applause]
I didn't do
it I didn't do it it wasn't me let's
open you
hey no let me open this let me open this
let me open it let me I'm not grabbing
you door I I can't all right you obvious
want me to go here so I'll
fine I'm
going I didn't even know why this place
is
huge I'm scared defo what are you
doing
what and when you gaze into the abbys
the abbis no more jumping hcha hcha hcha
hcha
hcha Drop It Like It's how drop it hcha
hcha hcha wh wh wh wh wh who wh wh wh
wooho oh yeah w w w w w w it's to F on
the
sh what the
[__] what the
hell Quest
roded
uhoh
oh
uhoh what is he going to
do what is he doing
stop doing
that stop
it no I don't think this is
working it's
Stu that mean I
win
a obvious jump scare [__]
[__] so confused right
now why do they make me do that
little girls aren't that scary I mean
those little girls aren't they holy [__]
I finish that shapter like a
boss oh
no no not you we do not start our battle
this way is that a statue did they get
the [__] statues to
move no
way what stop nodding at me I'm breaking
Ching my way out of
here come on man we can do
it what where did he go get up your ass
Daniel we're not finish with this [__]
yet it's no finito
El let's go in here Adventures nothing
was in here I don't even care what's in
the other one I didn't even have my
Lantern anymore son of a [__] they made
me find my Lantern just to lose
it
that's nice not going in
there [__] anyone for telling me where
to go all
right
what
what stop stop not
funny [__]
you woof woof on you too man son of a
barrel son of a oh thank you
Heaven no no not today not today let me
click that save like and fav you enjoy
subscribe go R today and um I'll see you
next episode of stay awesome brother I
know you
will
activate
you [__]
[__] son of a [__] I'm keep going
then I don't didn't get no sh stops [__]
all right oh